[Music]
hey welcome back it's Jesse I'm here at
the Wolfram the tech conference just
talking with various developers and
other people using all from technology
in really interesting ways
I'm here with Mateo could you tell me a
little bit about what you do here at
Wolfram and what you were talking about
at the conference tonight yeah so and
what for my work as a developer in the
machine learning framework we particular
focus on neural networks joined the
company two years ago and we working in
a good system only to talks and it's
conference one about basically what's
new in the frameworks when it was an
extended version of what we talked about
here and and then I didn't talk about
the water more natural paucity which is
our our curated collection of
pre-trained so can you just for the
audience can you tell us a little bit
about what makes them go from neural net
framework you know so the main advantage
of a framework is that is ease of use
with respect to X like other external
frameworks it's very high level you
don't have to type much code to do
things compared to true to other
frameworks and and it has very extensive
accurate documentation and it's
perfectly integrated with the rest of
the line
so these are some of the more
interesting features so the the neural
net repository works with the framework
wouldn't use a sure sure it's perfectly
integrated you can download free train
models high-quality curated pretty
models which are usually conversions of
like state-of-the-art models for various
tasks and you can download them into
your mathematical section just calling
with just one line of code so yes there
is lots of integration on that side too
awesome nice
so with version 12 what are some of the
newer functions that y'all are
introducing yeah so there was lots of
improvements we had some layers and some
new training debugging facilities and
also some speed ups the main areas we
[Music]
know someone mentioned reinforcement
learning I don't know what that is sure
can you explain yes so enforcement
learning is is one paradigm of machine
learning in which you don't have data
like static the static data you have to
learn from but you have an environment
and your your machine learning system
which is called an agent in this in this
context interacts with that environment
and gets either penalties of rewards and
so you you train your agent by its
interaction with environment and the
unusual application that people think
about is is like playing video games so
you can teach an AI system to play a
video game and that is not static data
then the system has to to to learn to
associate inputs to outputs like in the
case of supervised learning or just
learn or just learn the general
structure of the data with unsupervised
learning but it has to interact with the
environment and learn what are they like
good news yes that is actually a heavy
job I forgot to mention so yes we we
will we will support reports of learning
for the first time so we will link with
Jim which is an important framework like
a collection of deep learning
environments and we will support
training of deep learning a personal
learning agents into the framework with
additional like an extended API for the
net training function which is what we
use to to train run networks
I see so you mentioned that the Wolfram
language and all that framework is sort
of good for its ease of use how does
this compare to something like yes well
they're very similar we'd say that like
Karis is the only other like high-level
language which compares to to us like
the closest the closest framework in
terms of high-level interface I'd say
that like one very one great advantage
we have is that
it's very like our premium it's very
well integrated with the rest of the
language while Kairos is a package that
you have to manually install and it
doesn't its usual situation in Python
you you you have to use many external
libraries developed by many many
different group of people which didn't
never met with each other and the user
experience is is smoother in our side
because it's yeah you show me a little
bit about what's on your sure so there
was lots to to show this is an excerpt
from the presentation I had and I'm just
just about to show you a couple of
lights out of it so about the speed ups
we have a much faster record or networks
view so you see that running these I am
creating a recurrent player I'm
evaluating it on some input so just very
simple benchmark and you can see that
the timing for this operation commercial
12 is 0.06 seconds while 11 point it was
0.15 so it's all malla fact almost a
factor 10 speed-up cpu which is another
very important thing to mention is
finally super simple multi-gpu
use age so you can just run either
training or evaluation networks on all
your GPUs by just using this option so
target device goes to GPU come also
previously we had target device GPU if
you have only one or target device GPU I
got some index if you have now you can
all and we just work seamlessly without
without having to go through driver
configuration sorry CUDA configurations
and so on which is another main selling
point for a framework
it comes with CUDA pre-installed latest
version you don't have to do anything
why usually the other situation you have
to spend a lot of time configuring it
correctly this comes out of the box
included in the layout you just have to
type target device GPU so denser core is
a new architecture which which ships
with some new generation GPUs and it was
it's an architecture which is focused to
which is focused for deep learning and
to accelerate deep learning it features
it basically it's it features like mix
precision calculation both in 16 and 32
bits and you can give like very very
high speed ups for so this is an example
so you can you can you can see the speed
up here for some convolution in some
like notable deep learning architecture
so
you can get along almost a factor of
four in some cases I mean it's it's it's
a very nice feature and we fully support
it 12
by using working position goes to mixed
so work is working precision is also
extended to there we go we have three
264 so this means that you can now
specify with a single option if we if
you want to work with either 30 bit
precision or 64 bits precision as well
as mid position if you have tons of
course the other notable improvement is
integration with numeric array so
numerically is a new feature coming in
12 so yeah so the mercury is basically a
wrapper over a typed numeric array like
you would I didn't see or something so
you can have you can specify this is
constructing a 5x5 matrix and wrapping
it over this numeric array or real 64 I
can actually specify what's the type I
want to use for this array and you can
have options you can have to be a 32 you
can have like integers and so on and so
forth so it gives you a more detailed
low-level access about not and and the
framework would be fully integrated with
this so
that's a very nice addition the main
advantage of these will be to you mean
yes it's mainly memory consumption
because you you you you can you can
really have like low-level control about
the representation of data your memory
and sometimes you just put for example
four integers most sometimes you can
just be fine with 8 bits so by
specifying and like integer 8 you will
have like very very efficient memory
memory management
okay so you've exhausted all my
questions do you have anything more you
want to say about language neural net
framework maybe to the users who are not
as familiar with our technology yeah
well again the main characteristic the
main feature of the framework is once
again is abuse so you usually need to
type much less code to to do to achieve
the same things in the framework with
respect to others and the results extent
very extensive and detailed
documentation with tutorials we'll be
talking with more developers a little
later on today
Thanks